on va parler maintenant nutrition les
années ce que vous achetez souvent des
plats cuisinés avec nos vies un peu
évidente quand on rentre tard le soir
ces pratiques les plats cuisinés le
monde
non non aux très bien madame parce que
je vous demande ça parce qu'il ya une
étude qui vient de sortir ou selon
laquelle la majeure partie d'entre nous
par nombre d'entre eux les plats
cuisinés contiendrait quasiment
absolument pas de lyon contrairement à
ce qui est indiqué sur l'étiquette c'est
un sujet du 13 heures de france 2 des
raviolis des cannellonis des lasagnes et
autres hachis parmentier tous ces
produits indique du boeuf
près de 60% des raviolis étudié au moins
de 8% de boeuf
seule une référence à taller 26% autre
constatation un produit plus cher ou
même bio ne garantit pas plus de viande
dans le plat sur l'étiquetage des
progrès restent à faire sur le type de
morceaux sur le plan nutritionnel une
majorité de plats contient du sucre
ajouté 88% des produits ont des agents
texturants de type épaississant et dans
26 % des cas il y a des conservateurs ou
exhausteurs de goût ces plats préparés
ne répondent pas aux besoins quotidiens
alors sur 47 référence à vous l'avez
entendu 60% contiennent moins de 8% de
viande
qu'est ce que vous en pensez à jimmy
mais c'est un scandale parce que et on
se doute bien que effectivement c'était
pas les plats du siècle on se doute bien
que un plat cuisiné comme ça ça vaut pas
la même chose qu'un plat fait à la
maison tranquillement mais néanmoins et
de la publicité manches longues
mensongère canton ouest où ces logos et
on voit hachis parmentier et convoi de
la viande on a quand même l'impression
est 100% avec la lgv à chaque moment sur
le produit et du coup on incite les
français à retourner tu as l'impression
que tu me regardes que je fais vraiment
un 95d beaucoup sur les produits c'est
la base de la vie c'est la base de la
france mais si le monde est comme ça au
moment où est ce qu'on a vraiment bien
pour ça que l'on accepte maintenant on
doit pas l'accepter social battre contre
service surtout avoir les yeux ouverts
mais au moins le minimum c'est
d'indiquer hachis parmentier moi je vais
indiquer à quel point 15 mai
vous estimez pas ce que c'est pourtant
un scribe alors il faut retourner à
causé un petit yanis d'ingrédients il
faut pas oublier de dire que souvent le
premier indien un gradient c'est
l'ingrédient principal
donc si vous rendez compte que
finalement le boeuf arrive en 6ème 7ème
position c'est qu'il ya un problème je
suis pas d'accord avec toi jimmy parce
que c'est vrai que l'on nous présente
cette enquête comme le scandale du
siècle voilà on peut tirer à boulet
rouge sur les industriels pour certaines
choses or là je suis désolé pour le coup
ils sont assez francs il n'y a pas eu
erreur sur la marchandise il suffit
juste que vous tourniez la boîte et vous
voyez la proportion de viande présente
dans la préparation par un pardon mais
je me faire l'avocat du diable
effectivement quand sur le devant de la
boîte il a écrit en très gros hachis
parmentier convoi écrit 100% alors on
sait pas bien 100% de quoi est ce que
c'est un dessin qui représente un boeuf
mais est ce que c'est vraiment voilà et
qu'en fait il faut retourner le truc et
c'est écrit en tout petit dans les
valeurs nutritionnelles énergétique et
sedar non mes gars clairement ils vont
lire je suis d'accord que c'est pas très
claires et c'est vrai qu'il faudrait que
ce le soit et si vous voulez savoir il
faut juste retourner la boîte et là vous
allez vraiment voir c'est quand même
assez simple après il ya le fameux nutri
score qui a été mis en place l'année
dernière
alors on ramait domaine et risque alors
c'est un label en fait qui permet de
classer la valeur nutritionnelle du
produit selon 2 a à d je crois exercer
le nutritionniste et d'essai c'est la
moins bonne est là et c'est ça tout
derniers produits qui sont nous
transformer c'est à dire à ce sera une
pomme par exemple
et puis un plat cuisiné larry brown et
parce qu'il est extrêmement transformer
a grillé un petit indice oui chérie
c'est le goût parce que si vous ouvrez
une boîte de raviolis voilà d'une marque
est fini en bain je sais pas vous avez
le comme un espèce de fourmi qui vous
vient dans les autres mois à ben oui
mais c'est parce que vous vous êtes très
particulière aussi enfin tout et puis et
puis il ya plein de gens qui achètent
ces boîtes de raviolis d'abord parce
qu'ils n'ont pas franchement joie oui
j'en ai pas forcément très très cher et
c'est de ça dont on a quand même un
petit peu de viol parce qu'il ya des
produits frais qui sont pas chères et
des pactes c'est pas cher et on peut
faire des pâtes seul avec des tomates
qu'on me fais cuire un peu de danse à
poil et puis voilà un truc quand on y
est on a une fille qui permet de rentrer
à la maison et de se mettre aux
fourneaux pour faire à manger à ses
enfants et parfois tout le monde ne peut
feindre un mec
oui pourquoi pas de mec
les noms meillard inactif avant cette
histoire jeu derrière un climat et le
pire c'est que ça fait quand même des
années qu'on entend maintenant parler de
ça mais c'est pas grave on continue de
vous gaver de trucs qui sont ignobles
pour notre santé et je suis désolé
damien c'est comme une femme
effectivement elle te montre un aspect
de sa personnalité bim surtout le truc
tu
non mais pas le truc bas mais je le dis
je veux tu creuses un peu c'est comme
aller chercher l'étiquette qui va
regarder le truc qui a écrit en un
millimètre et c'est dès que tu creuses
un peu tu te rends compte que la
promesse finalement on ne convient pas
trop on a posé la question non je pose
la question sur twitter les plats
cuisinés à la viande sans viande 1 ou
quasiment
est ce que vous êtes surpris ou bien
vous vous en doutiez ben oui vous vous
en doutiez à 69 vous avez quand même 31
% avouent déclaré surpris du peu de
pourcentage de viande danser dans ses
plats tout préparés
en tout cas j'ai vous qui j'ai vu
comment il goûté les plats pour les
assaisonner c'est pas trop ça y est
[Applaudissements]
tout vous dire nous tombe dessus et doué
en cuisine ça pourrait être moi je
pouvais gagner tout le temps la même
qu'hier de l'autre ça pourrait pas être